thank you
[Music]
I'm just not ready to have to take care
of another human being it's not your
fault it's the man's it's not my
responsibility a baby is not the
mother's responsibility baby I just want
to make sure that I'm making the right
decision you know because I'm so young
and I've got my whole life ahead of me
and I wasn't trying to do this and it's
stupid
yeah baby it's not your fault that you
let a man in you so I should go back to
being selfish yes be a selfish woman get
rid of your baby
not
cute yeah you got an ugly preemie
bearded baby
it doesn't cry I think it has Asperger's
that's going to be even more expensive
special schools
you gotta get rid of it just throw it
into stupid baby River
you're right
yeah there you go he doesn't even cry I
think he has Asperger's
kick it just kill come on pick the baby
kick the baby
see Bobby it's having a great time going
down the river he's not even scared
right this was the right choice yeah I
know what was the choice I wouldn't
steer you wrong
if he sees wrong he's dead
[Music]
all the way
[Music]
to reach out mine
oh myself
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
well oh
yeah
one man's trash got a new slave
everybody oh got a new slave you ever
catch a slave this big Frank no you
didn't new slave right here oh well oh
wow
let's get out of here
why don't you cry
you have Asperger's
foreign
.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
but really it's just uh drying lights so
we have a lot to get to today Russia
Ukraine still going on still still going
okay yeah I thought we were past this I
thought Joe Biden's strong words helped
you know what Russia we're on cocaine
you have a lot of growing up to do
Russia okay
I'll tell you that right now
you have a lot of growing up to do
you know it really hurts the most is a
lack of respect Dave will end The
Invasion well yeah but you know what
hurts the second most is the lack of
respect well in the killings yes what
hurts the third most is a lack of
respect grow up Russia and name that
movie line for people right off the bat
uh we have a lot to get so by the way if
we're never on YouTube and we have no
idea because they were going after tick
tock we're talking about the CDC we're
talking about masks we're talking about
Russia these things can become a problem
we are live Monday through Thursday 10
a.m Eastern on Rumble or my glove
letterscore.com we'll have an extra like
45 minutes to an hour today it's chat
Thursday my favorite day of the week so
uh
let me introduce Gerald a how are you I
am well sir how are you I'm I was so
tired yesterday after the stream
recovering from that is tough well it's
because you don't sleep for hours you're
amped exactly that's why like Dave has a
problem uh you know going from like when
he's doing the gigs on the weekends back
when he used to have to do more like you
know five shows in a weekend and then
coming back to doing stuff in the
morning you know I thought he I thought
he had uh I thought he had narcolepsy
for a while Asperger's no no this is
Moses oh wow yeah that's Moses uh you
know him you love him Dave Landau how
are you Ahoy good how about you good
were you tired yesterday uh little [ __ ]
we came in did some stuff yep we have
some sketches uh that we're gonna be
showing you today here's here's my
question my question before anything
else is we'll be talking about Russia
and now the censoring of Russian media
you see this on Apple you see this on is
it called is it still called like the
the app store because I switched iTunes
to just Apple well it's App Store okay
it's still the App Store what comment
below that's the best thing again you
can do for the YouTube algorithm but it
also helps us kind of get a good idea
because people are torn on this do you
support censoring the Russian media do
you think that's a good idea right now
to try and squeeze them and get rid of
Russian media on social platforms right
now or do you think that just ends up
again driving them into the arms of
people who could be more evil creating
the idea is maybe we want to revolt and
dissent against the Russian government
from the Russian people but does it just
make them hate America more like we've
seen in the past so I you know I think
you know where I line up but maybe you
don't uh before we move on to that I
think we'll also be talking about what
by the way I don't know if you know this
Sam Elliott joined the Westboro Baptist
Church did did he really yeah remember
number nine oh yes remember number nine
hands and now toe tags for certain types
I'm the only one in this church that
doesn't have flippers oh boy so uh we'll
be talking about Sam Elliott quite a bit
I'm excited about that also Russia
Ukraine but first uh Pittsburgh channel
their channel 4 Action News uh it proves
you know because we're National yeah
this is a national show yeah I call it
International really yeah yeah it's on
the internets yep and we have some fans
in uh in Japan until we get caught do
you realize every cold bear segment we
do gets copyright struck and it's not
available in Japan really I don't know
why deprived
I don't know why you cannot watch our
segments on Stephen Colbert in Japan
specifically I think it's called bear
they have a problem with it not so much
us no no no no no no no no oh no they
love Colbert huge in Japan
he has like a 90 million dollar contract
with Sanctuary times you can get his
underwear out of a vending machine yes
you can yes you can right in Tokyo I
want your panties with more intensity
Colbert panty another movie line but
first this proves Pittsburgh's channel 4
Action News that there's still a place
for we can't serve all roles local news
it's not clear what may have been taken
and no arrests have been made a 71 year
old man is accused of inappropriately
touching a 12 year old girl at the
Walmart in West Mifflin Sunday afternoon
not a joke the best is the other anchor
hold on a second
I just want to make sure we this is 100
real tokin Owen this is real we're sure
this is real it's on the internet yeah
it is real must be real
riding a unicorn with a scythe look even
if it's not real it's funny yeah but I
wanna even if it's not real it's also
real yes exactly
all right let's play what's getting
canned for that let's play this again
because I want to see that guy's
reaction it's worse the and boom goes
the dynamite kid it's it's really good
here what may have been taken and
she has no idea 12 year old girl at the
Walmart in West Mifflin
[Laughter]
that he's actually just glad it's not
his picture yeah yeah
oh man that was close it was a relief
it's like when you get to when you think
your report card is coming home and you
accidentally get someone else's you're
like this is Shane Brampton I'm Sean
Proctor like
hey just bring it to my parents you just
dodged a bullet that's a 20 bill right
there wow she has no idea what's going
on she's probably in front of a green
that's the problem with green screen
yeah I you should have a monitor though
right yeah but she's not really her
fault she's not controlling it it still
hurts someone who's hilarious is she's
on air she has a picture of Joseph Biden
I would have ran with it hold on time
out if they fire you for that call us
yes
call us we're not saying you'll be on
air but call us but you know look we
need janitors too well well she's
running that burgundy she just
whatever's in front of her she goes go
screw yourself Pittsburgh
oh my gosh yeah that one was sent to us
from our very own brat again it is it is
real wow yep what is it keep it trashy
Pittsburgh
I love the Squirrel Hill Pittsburgh all
right here's something else we have to
talk about uh I don't know if you know
this but uh uh we all know that masks of
course I shouldn't say I don't know if
you know this we all know that masks are
one billion percent effective against
covid yes
um but now
apparently now they're nuke proof oh
really did you know this I've heard yeah
maybe from the CDC the new CDC
guidelines uh encourage everyone to mask
up in the event of a nuclear explosion
it says when you have reached a part of
your household if possible wear a mask
if you're Sheltering with people who are
not a part of your household so if
there's a nuclear explosion uh this is
the science by the way just to be clear
let me ask you this do you think do you
think there's we can't find one
legitimate scientist outside the CDC
who's like oh yeah your n95 is not gonna
it's not gonna stop a nuke
oh
this is the dumbest thing I've heard
they got bigger problems than if I have
a mask on fellas yeah it's gonna happen
you would think so but this is more to
me more so this highlights the idea of
the science well yeah where are the
actual there's not one Doctor Who will
speak up I mean are we are we at Sodom
and Gomorrah with the science like are
there not 10 good scientists left I
think that's fair is it Hiroshima I
think a few people made it who were
wearing masks yes
absolutely yeah just Rip Van Winkle came
out with his n95 oh what happened here
seems they laid waste explored for my
cotton mask
something happened the heavens above
that I had my neck gaiter
my wife had triplets with one body
and if this worked the nukes are
irrelevant well that would yes yeah
nukes are relevant is like what we've
been trying to figure out how to stop a
nuclear Holocaust we've been trying to
figure out how to avoid nuclear war
a few masks I feel the nuke goes off
we're all just done right no no not well
you would be not but now if you have a
mask not if you have oh right yeah it's
almost as effective as getting under
your table people from the 50s who are
still here yeah plywood will take care
of yeah exactly
that's all you need in the event of a
nuke just get under soft Pine yeah
that's all it takes it's not even a hard
wood it's not even a fruit wood stupid
so we actually obtained uh footage from
a PSA uh from the CDC of course now the
propaganda comes uh giving instructions
on how to stay safe
you may be in your schoolyard playing
when the signal comes that signal means
to stop whatever you're doing and get to
the nearest safe place fast
if Putin aligns with China an atomic
bomb can come at any time no matter
where you may be if you're at school get
in a single file line and Crouch
underneath a desk
and if you're a smart kid apply your
mask because a mask is the most
important line of defense between you
and nuclear annihilation
[Music]
good job alive kids
die matchless dead ones
[Music]
think it all could have been stopped
with just just one one trip over to the
Quick Trip grab a few masks no they hit
a pinwheel hat on it how long was he
gonna live
maybe 19. you'd still have your brother
I know well it's his fault
triplets there's always one goofball
[Laughter]
something about the placenta yeah
there's only enough to there's not
enough to go around we like to think
there is enough for everybody there
isn't it number three sorry there's uh
one thing that I noticed when I watch
that is um I really missed dresses that
ladies used to wear
a little different a little different
yeah they went above the ankle you got
whacked with a ruler yeah exactly that's
the whole thing it leaves a little bit
you know how I like turtlenecks I like
it dresses everything to the imagine it
leaves everything to the imagination
which is usually better than reality
yeah I like a uh what's the word [ __ ]
yeah
I mean I'm just saying in the initial
fit sooner or later you I mean you'll
want a professional well sure I mean
that one time that was very suitable yes
like that's the one you bring home to
your parents you're like look at this
right this one that's not garbage yeah
she looks like garbage but just don't
look in the trunk yep so
DeSantis Rhonda said here's one thing
too I just want to talk about with the
Russia before going I just this is
something that's been really bothering
me is you either need to be all in or
all out with war and if you look at the
actions that we're taking we have the
economic sanctions and now the censoring
is taking place of Russian media it re
and also other actions that will harm Uh
Russian citizens we're basically we're
basically committing acts of War without
Waging War either go into war or don't
this is a problem with modern society
we're so removed from the cruelty of
humanity we're so removed from the
reality of war that we just think oh you
know what if we starve people if we may
if we make sure that economically
they're crippled they won't do it do you
realize that the wars were fought for
exactly that yeah throughout history I
know someone right there in the comments
gonna look oh religion no dummy snow
all wars are fought over land over
resources over the ability to survive
and we're at this anyway okay we'll get
to it yeah yeah I'm just frustrated I'm
just angry you got to take a breath if
you're going to do something you should
go all in especially with I don't know
or I thought you said [ __ ] no so
Rhonda that would apply yeah the point
is it's a multi-faceted yeah I mean if
you're gonna pay idiom
uh to a bird in the hand and something
in the trees the point is we're gonna
nuke you so Ron DeSantis uh this is
something too that I absolutely love uh
he made news this week uh world of masks
news by he was at an event right at um
was it USF USF USF okay so he was at
this event I always forget yeah I always
forget the event uh the event names USF
it's abbreviations I don't do well with
it but I do know exactly what it is that
he did and thank God you know what I
know he didn't come in first in the
straw poll at CPAC which is is almost
entirely irrelevant but uh I
I want this guy in our corner see if you
can tell why you do not have to wear
those masks I mean please
honestly it's not doing anything and we
got to stop with this code is theater so
if you want to wear it fine but this is
a this is ridiculous
[Music]
I love that he didn't you know sometimes
you have people like look I just you
know I think Pete some people should
wear masks and then just say no it's
stupid it's stupid and you look stupid
yeah well these are University of South
Florida so USF South Florida right so
they're students sitting there and
they're like oh you gotta wear masks
there was no nuke threat no there was no
desk to get under either where's the
plywood well I don't know I'm sure she
meant some interns you can get under a
Podium yeah but I've done it I've seen
Police Academy yeah that's a Podium for
one Dave so yeah well he's missing the
point yeah you find the most important
guy in the room and he gets under the
podium yes so not that's who lives then
you become Kamala Harris yeah so here's
the thing man in the room and we'll talk
about the science we'll talk about some
of the new updates that have taken place
but what's funny is most of the kids
obviously you saw were were stoked they
were excited uh probably because they've
read the science or the anti-science
however you want to refer to it but
there still was one mom who apparently
hasn't gotten the memo and this is the
problem with the country country right
now when people say oh we're divided
ideologically no we're not divided
ideologically we really are at this
point divided by the informed and the
dogmatic that's where we are on covid
the informed and the dogmatic and here
is a dogmatic mother who was just beside
herself
I'm responsible for him and I told him
to wear that mask
and Governor DeSantis and he's looking
at this adult Authority and he's telling
him oh you didn't have to wear the mask
what was your reaction when you heard
the governor tell you and your
classmates remove your masks
um a bit of a surprise and shock more of
okay this Authority I thought this
authority figure is asking me to do
something that I know is he has to
answer that way because she'll beat his
ass as soon as the camera stops rolling
she knows she's not wearing a mask
take off your mask he pretty much said
take off your mask is stupid and take
off your mask your parents don't matter
correct even though I'm I'm telling you
parents doesn't matter but you're not
you're telling my minor child to take
off his mask he's putting us at risk oh
Lord so oh yeah I was upset very upset
yeah well I think that you just live to
be up I wish that I loved anything as
much as you love being upset
there's so many never have a hobby like
that never
she's like uh Jamie Foxx with a violin
in that movie with Robert Downey Jr she
just Lo she lives to be upset everything
she just said not only not to mention
she was redundant with my minor child
will we get it
but she is sitting there saying you know
it's just it's wrong and is saying that
you shouldn't wear masks and and uh
we're putting us at risk your teenager
is at risk from Omicron this is somebody
who is not again it's the
formed and the dogmatic I know you're
saying shouldn't it be informed and
uninformed well no it goes without
saying the informed but then the
dogmatic there is a religion now of fear
and of covet and there are certain
people who no matter how much it changes
yeah they have to hold on to it like
this mother and they have to try and
make it miserable for everybody else by
the way what you're saying is that
you're frustrated as a parent an
authority figure you're saying is doing
your job for you where are you on
critical race Theory where are you in
public schools teaching reality issues
to kids are you upset do you believe
that those issues should be left to the
parents to teach or do you want to put
that in the hands of public education
again
it requires inconsistency to maintain
the current position so whatever gets a
lawsuit right I mean that's what that is
it's just setting up for an ability to
get a lawsuit it's like a slip and fall
but the mask slips right exactly by the
way your kid is in college right when
would you like them to start making
decisions for themselves
I'm sorry he's growing when the check
clears [ __ ] and by the way he didn't
say anything about parents not mattering
he said if you want to wear these go for
it he didn't say your mom and dad may
have told you to wear these so stop
trying there's more to this story and I
and I absolutely adore it because the
mother and the son is there and you know
that he's responding it's almost like
you know he's a little senior wences
like isn't that right that's right Mom
you always right you right you right
right you right but the thing is this is
my mom she used to [ __ ] me with
bathing so I grabbed a candy bar yeah
please don't make me pick my own switch
not again so the CDC uh eased mask
restrictions as you well know they even
said even fauci talked about this uh and
it's location it's risk based you can
bring up the overlay also there's this
Danish study in a Bloomberg article both
of which said that masks
basically make little to no difference
okay now here's my I can't make that
point we can't make this point because
on YouTube you can be removed so in
other words if you're a scientist and
you actually say well you know what if
we look at masks and we look at the way
that people are wearing them they're not
really effective so Bloomberg and a
Danish study daneland
it's nothing
um wrote These articles which were very
compelling hey you know who else must
have read these articles hmm
the sun oh
[Music]
my gosh please send this to that mother
that's awesome
I can't believe it you were happy to
take your mask off why it was the
governor that ear to ear grin of just
like oh thank God it's so hot in here
now I can breathe oh thank you Governor
you made a fool them me a local news
[ __ ] but she's gonna be furious with
her yeah I was shocked and upset and
happy
all at the same time
we find that kid and have him on the
show oh that'd be great just not his mom
I don't unders I'd like to talk to his
mom though because everything she said
was a giant contradiction but she's not
wearing a mask she um that's my point
though she can't say any of it it
doesn't matter son of a [ __ ] I'm 19
time boosted yeah also why is he
bringing it home to you oh you live at
home I thought it was a college you
should be quarantining I did not want to
pay for dormitories well that's true he
stays at home it's expensive yeah like
that's the worst thing he's gonna catch
ever heard of in-state tuition mother
I don't think he's transmitting the
other things to his mind
I hope not if he's wondering if they
share a glass
if he's wearing his mask how can he
engage in four years of glorified
alcoholism for two hundred thousand
dollars right exactly strainer yeah yeah
that's true you can leave with a degree
that people go uh yeah right yeah all
right uh you know what I saw your mom on
the news oh okay we'll give you an intro
get out of here fine go bring me coffees
now uh here's something that I just love
the story uh from Sam Elliott I'm a Sam
Elliott fan I know he's not necessarily
on our side of the political Spectrum
but
he is partially so I was about to say
you know that Benedict Cumberbatch film
news wants the power of the dog yeah
it's uh yeah certified fresh which is a
stupid term uh 94 of critics uh gave it
a positive review knowing Rotten
Tomatoes uh but Sam Elliott is actually
he's he's really not a fan he was asked
about it recently on a podcast and some
of the comments are hysterical but you
had a point that you wanted to know well
I mean look I think Hollywood is totally
missing the boat here if you've watched
Yellowstone if you've watched what is it
1883 or whatever that the other one
after that yeah all right let's just
make as many westerns as we can make but
when I watch that when my wife watches
that we look at it we're like oh man
like they're saying stuff that we agree
with like there's scenes where they're
talking about tough love for kids and
making them into pets because you're
giving them too many things and it's not
going to be a good thing and then
there's like just the toughness of being
a man and having to go out and be a
cowboy and work hard for a living and
Hollywood is like oh well let's just
make more westerns with you know none of
those elements involved in it at all and
instead what they should be doing is
going huh there's this giant segment of
America that's being missed and I think
you were making the point that Sheridan
the guy who wrote it is basically what
he has tapped into is that through line
through all of his stuff is that there
is a segment of America that's been left
behind that these movies really do speak
to and these shows really do speak to
and it makes them feel like oh you know
what that's right there are some bad
things that we have to get rid of in
society for sure but these things are
great these things are conservative
values and some of the tough love that
we don't have anymore he was also in
Tombstone which is well that's my money
my favorite Western it is whatever but
it was also considered kind of a dead uh
medium well that's true but Tombstone
brought it back yes and so did unforget
Sammy Sam Elliott was in Tombstone yeah
that's right I thought you meant
Sheridan he's here what the heck
Sam Sam Elliott who actually decided to
take some time
to read son of a [ __ ]
you should have got him the big cowboy
hat headphones the New York Post
took my ass out of context
I'd like to read my thoughts on Benedict
Cumberbatch
these are the exact quotes
and all references are available
Atlanta with grunner.com and the pinned
comment
that's what all these [ __ ] Cowboys in
that movie looked like
Chippendales dancers
they're all running around in chaps and
no shirts
there's all these Illusions to
homosexuality
throughout the whole [ __ ] film
where's the Western in this Western
I mean Cumberbatch never got out of his
[ __ ] traps
get two pairs of chaps
woolly pear
and the leather pair
[Music]
and every [ __ ] time he would walk in
from somewhere
he never once was on a horse
he'd walk into the [ __ ] house
storming up the [ __ ] stairs to go
laying his bed in his chaps and play his
banjo it's like what the [ __ ]
I just think there's a problem with
modern westerns
a lot of homosexual undertones and
Hoover Tunes in this movie
and I made my living
and filmed you know that Gerald and Dave
right you did at uh Tombstone I just
mentioned you were great on that all I
have to say for my own
from my own job security I'm a little
concerned
I used to make films with
Grace like Kurt Russell and Bill Paxton
now if I want to work out there in the
range I have to get pegged by Brian
stelter oh geez
no I don't give a red chance what the
union says you're going to have to pay
my sorry ass more than [ __ ] scary
hole
I wouldn't even let my dog watch this
movie
[Laughter]
matter of fact I'd rather watch Magic
Mike with an unpeeled banana in my mouth
why does the woman leave this is for
people who've watched the actual I have
a [ __ ] movie
why did that woman leave oh cause you
like him better
look
I'm not one to protest a funeral and say
that God hates me you can't say the f
word right no no no Sam don't do that
but just because it's no longer unlawful
doesn't mean it's not immoral and
disgusting
I hate Hollywood and I hate its liberal
queerness
I also hate that God forsaken podcast
that made this a story
you know we're getting some comments
Maybe
if 15 000 of your
hit like in the next five minutes I'll
have to host the rest of this show
here is Sam Elliott
I really hope it's an unattainable goal
it might be uh I don't know Sam I think
you could do it I think Sam Ellie could
do anything he can
he was a cowboy he actually worked just
because you can do something
doesn't mean you should well like making
a film with Benedict Cumberbatch and
chaplis ass pants getting pegged by
whoever won't even get a sick and look
for best supporting actor
more like best best supporting queer did
you like him in Doctor Strange you big
Doctor Strange fan
I'm not a huge fan of the Marvel
Universe now mainly because it's
surrounded with queers ah same thing
mainly yeah which one do you think is
the most gay well
I think you'd have to take into account
that the Hulk when he switches from
Bruce Banner
a wimpy ass queer scientist into the
world's most powerful superhero
all those clothes rip off except his
pants how convenient
I think it's remarkably inconsistent
I also think that
we never see him from behind because
those are assless purple pants
are you sure about that I think he's I'm
not sure I'll make I'm not sure I'm
making an inference by God have you seen
any of these movies well the problem now
is I'm about 85 with my cataracts I
can't see much I think you're 77 but
that doesn't mean I can't tell right
from wrong damn it
oh
do you still like Marlboros
I'm actually a Chesterfield man okay
yeah I don't make them anymore which
makes them hard to save makes them hard
to come by what was that I just wonder
if you saved the cartons
why would I save the curtains this is
this is the guy you have here this is
what I'm talking about don't put him in
some new Western along Kevin Costner no
I'd be very gay but he does his new new
show out there supposed to be on the
Range like we don't know that he's
faking his voice well we all saw you in
the postman
I got a question I mean what do you
think about uh not Kevin Costner great
great movie great movie um Brokeback
Mountain what was you what were your
thoughts
son of a [ __ ]
did you see what you did there
and that's the problem with our society
I mean could you quit him is not
everything is required to be an
undertone or in your case overtone of
homosexuality I think that one's blatant
I don't even know if it's a tone can we
just go back to the days where
I remember we had
one miss and Margaret
Raquel Welch
they've been replaced with
guys I said One Direction
One Direction and New Kids on the Block
s your references seem a little dated I
don't care how many times Backstreet's
back huh I won't be there for it
and I certainly won't put them in a
western
all right look I'm gonna take one moment
even though I
not happy to have to do it but I'm
contractually obligated okay to push
this queer [ __ ]
apparently Stephen Crowder and Dave
Landau are on tour
because that's still allowed in this
country
Dave's going to be at the Funny Bone in
Hartford Connecticut
March 18th through 19th
then in Tulsa Oklahoma on May 14th in
Colorado Springs
June 18th we're going to have both
Crowder and Dave
where you can bet that you'll probably
have a few at least sub closeted
homosexuals in the audience oh here we
go so long as you're comfortable with it
I don't know if you're comfortable with
yourself saying are you are you good
with you who you are much neither here
nor there I I think it's I don't have to
be comfortable with myself to not be
comfortable with a couple of queers on
the Range who have never ridden a horse
in their life they wouldn't know what to
do with a saddle if it was pegged up
their own asses oh I think it can fit I
think they know not to do that yeah well
I don't know if they know there's some
from their Peckerwood you don't get
tired of riding fences Sam
riding horses
a little reference no no right is that
you trying to be clever I'm just saying
we used two lines from the song
desperado this man is doing songs from
the what you just did are you doing runs
but almost that was uncomfortable you
know just because it's not against the
law it doesn't mean that you're
attempted comedy doesn't get lonely out
there it's not offensive to the
sensibilities
or I need someone to
take the camera so that what did you get
out of this
where's the host
and being a cowboy kind of like prison
Dave where you're just surrounded by
other guys and you're like well
this is now life I guess oh yeah I think
it's an excuse I'm just saying for God's
sakes thanks for uh oh yeah thanks for
letting me have to I can't do it
Sam has to leave he does we got to give
you know I can't believe you got him on
the show well that's yeah we did pretty
well get him to promote our stand up
dates yeah that's that's exciting he was
not happy about it I mean he didn't have
to call us about to say Tim uh we didn't
hit the uh perfect good okay actually I
was watching the number go up and then
it went down it went down it hit 15 700
likes and then it got tacked down to 15
100 likes oh wow they are not Samuel so
that's pretty good though you actually
did hit the mark yeah well no no this
was just it doesn't matter we were at 9
000 it went to oh all right yeah I think
that's a limited time only kind of thing
okay so I'm really trying to push it as
if it wasn't
we did a show where Bernie Sanders
hosted the entire show in Donald Trump
and people didn't realize that they
weren't real
[Laughter]
very upset yes why does he have Bernie
hosting his show why is he roast why is
he making fun of trump says I mean it's
burning
uh all right here's another thing so
this is something that just happened and
it's unbelievable to me because I heard
Bill Gates say this
and I thought well he can't say that no
no no because I was just he's Bill Gates
yeah he's Bill Gates so you can say that
but there's a silver lining yeah for me
Playbook so Bill Gates this is about
Omicron Bill Gates uh just said recently
that Omicron has worked better as a
vaccine than actual vaccines this is
Bill Gates the vaccine guy listen where
would you assess where we are today in
beating covet 19.
well the uh you know sadly the virus
itself particularly the the variant
called Omicron uh is a type of vaccine
that is it creates both b-cell and T
Cell immunity and it's done a better job
of getting out to the world population
uh than we have with vaccines first off
get a comb second who else
it just seems weird to me some it's it's
a billionaire with a bowl cut who else
said this
we now have a variant Omicron okay yeah
we have a variant which is significantly
more transmissible okay communicable
whatever term you want to use it as out
competed Delta and the original it is
the primary variant right it has
overtaken all the other variants if
you're catching uh coven now you're very
likely catching Omicron okay so now it's
taken over all the more deadly forms of
covid it's become the form of covet that
everyone catches and the vast majority
of people have very little symptoms
according to the CDC according to them
not us you could argue that Omicron is
responsible for reducing deaths more
than the vaccines
so wait a second but I if Bill Gates
said it
and I said it but I was raked over the I
was in trouble for saying the exact same
thing
trying to
[Music]
I own Microsoft
yeah so okay good yeah go ahead and sell
cash out so all right good news big day
this is exactly right yesterday's band
content is today sound science well
Stephen you're not a you're not a
scientist so I am not a scientist and
this is uh you know the doctor of
Microsoft no I'm not a doctor of
Microsoft I didn't go and smash all of
my competitors tables with baseball bats
no hey my bowl cut it was effective it's
always tough like they have to put his
lower third because like is that uh the
second richest richest man in the world
or is it a lesbian librarian I'm not
sure I'm going librarian it's the rich
guy yeah it's like a Batman villain but
it didn't go all the way right yes and
his superpower would be to go shhh
and the librarian I'm I'm librarian
I'll charge you late fees for books you
never knew you had
shh I won't pay him listen librarian
here Thomas I said
you know it's frustrating to only be
right three months later yeah well
here's the thing this is you know what I
want to if you guys can comment again
best thing for the algorithm but if you
guys have experienced Omicron we did
this poll a long time ago and a lot of
you had had Omicron and they were very
mild symptoms people in this office most
people who had Omicron I had Omicron uh
and it was actually I did less severe
than when I had a sinus infection a
couple weeks after that I wish people
say that came from the no it didn't I
tested negative for a long time here's
the issue and Trevor Noah who by the way
do we know is Trevor Noah going to be on
the show there talking now because he
because he reached out to us and then we
reached back out to Trevor Noah yeah
he's we haven't heard back yet still
right oh okay so Trev
don't say that why not nobody calls him
Trev that's the short for Trevor uh to
who what yeah to white to white guys who
want to sound this isn't Family Matters
this is 90s names you know there's uh
there's no fresh prince but he made this
argument he said uh you know that these
people now who are claiming that they're
right these people now who are claiming
that they're right well sure but you
were wrong 15 times no here's the thing
it's not that it's not like a psychic uh
who just says uh your husband is uh
Barry Bob Bruce right and gets it right
finally it what matters is did this
science exist at the time were the
people you trusted were making those
claims so for example fauci when fauci
said that aids was airborne and kids
could catch it in their home at their
breakfast nook were there other
scientists at that time saying it's
wrong we didn't just make some wild
prediction here on this show and I'm not
a scientist we did make an inference
based on all the data available so when
people try and say oh well you're right
now because Bill Gates says it
apparently he's a scientist they say
well you're right now but it doesn't
mean that you were right then you were
just guessing at random hold on a second
you were trusting people simply because
they were authority figures and you've
decided now that you believe in
authoritarianism as it relates to
science because it's not a it's not a
practice that's not a theory it's a
religion but at that time was there
scientific data and were there
dissenting scientists saying actually
it's probably a better idea to let
Omicron spread at this point because
it's the best we can hope for with a
very that did exist at that time you
chose to dismiss them so it's not
guessing at random we in January didn't
just say that
we didn't say it Willy no yeah we've
done a lot of research and it was
dismissed and it was attacked as radical
when there were many many where do you
think we got it scientists the ones who
use silence now Bill Gates is saying
they're right doesn't it feel
embarrassing to be wrong always what do
you mean lockdowns masks vaccines you
can't spread it the booster and another
booster Omicron I mean shutting down
schools
but take your you've been wrong about
from a lab
that had it in the title the best one it
was the covid-19 research lab nobody saw
that coming 19 generating lab I'm sorry
yes yes potentially it was the bats the
sandwich covid-19 left right
said nothing to do with
but they were actually vampires well I
assume so that's what I do one of them
was making fellow Lugosi eyes at me
seriously though this is a stranger
people hoping that they're bats
but in a decision take the bats swap
them out for humans swap them out for
the unvaccinated right we blame bats had
nothing to do it wasn't bats
wasn't it wasn't a bad problem they
couldn't find it in bats in nature now
we switch it out to the unvaccinated are
the problem that are spreading it no
you just heard Bill Gates say that
Omicron is more effective than vaccine
Omicron penetrates the vaccine so swap
out bats for human beings and what do
you do when you're dishonest and you
don't allow voices of multiple voices
dissenting voices differing opinions at
the table you end up scapegoating
someone or something that doesn't
deserve to be scapegoated that's how it
happens not saying thought she's a Nazi
not what I am saying is doesn't start a
beagle would yeah very much we're crying
out loud that's like it's like Auschwitz
it is it's worse for beagles but what I
am saying is anytime you you decide you
decide for some reason especially when
it's arbitrary on an authority figure
who you will who you will file follow
blindly or in this case a group of
authoritative figures who you will
follow blindly
that's how it becomes very easy to other
people meaning to create a class of
others and by the way what isn't this an
irony that the left is so obsessed with
diversity you know we have to have no
they're not we have to have enough
people with Afros on this board of uh
ethnobot and that's I thought
ethnobotany was a ficus and a fro turns
out there's a whole thing I always
explain it to me that is agree in it but
the point is they have to have all the
different colors and shapes and if
someone's 350 pounds they get they get
some kind of a Pell Grant but when it
comes to science
which is supposed to be the practice of
testing a hypothesis Every Which
possible way to come to the most
accurate conclusion we don't care about
the intellectual diversity at all if
intellectual diversity in science is not
then don't act then diversity is not a
thing it doesn't matter there's a no
it's the only place where diversity
actually is a strength
they care about visual diversity and
that's about it but here's the other
thing you told the whole world to trust
China and for the first time in history
most of them were like well they said it
okay I guess we have who says that
didn't happen like that in China because
China said it didn't yes judging by
their own citizens China has always had
your best interest at heart well they do
especially as they're peeling you out of
your apartment to take you to a place
where you're going to or totally
recovered right yeah Dave just made an
excellent point that's that is the nail
on the head and I want to highlight he
said judging by its citizens when people
try to say that you're we're not pushing
Asians in front of a subway train by the
way run the numbers see who's committing
the vast majority of anti-asian hate
crimes in this country but you said if
you look at the citizens why are we
trusting when we are trusting
that covet came from a you know a bat
that occurred in nature we're trust we
are trusting the government the same
government yeah who runs their citizens
over with tanks who commits genocide if
you care about the Chinese people you
should hate whatever is your natural set
point should be despise anything coming
from the Chinese government a lot of
people try and say they're one on the
same that's a great example you know who
suffers most the Chinese citizens when
Americans trust the Chinese Labs
government funded of course because they
look at it as if it's racist because
they don't understand that the Chinese
government Chinese citizens are two
different things they just go oh you
hate Asians and they leave it as a
blanket statement right it just shows
more of the ignorance of this country
yeah and how everything has become a
racial topic I'm not a big fan of I'm
not a big fan of the the Mongols
I'll say it the Mongolian the Lloyds how
many of them do you know well I know
enough that they had to build a wall to
keep them out well I think that was the
Genghis Khan keep them in yeah they were
just like all right here he wasn't nice
that's enough out of you impregnating
the entire Asian continent I think
everybody in this room has a little bit
of cone in them yeah I think so too the
wall was basically the world's first
giant it was a prophylactic yep didn't
work oh I can't put in the water stone
almost not comfortable yeah that guy
just killed people and made love well
what else make love is an awfully kind
way to put it yeah that's true rape yeah
on her face I don't care I get me oh go
oh no more stone wall oh
people are awful and the Chinese
government the people in charge so
corrupt do you know how the Great Wall
of China was breached how they paid
someone at the gate to let them through
that's always how it happened that's
what happens when you have people
working for the government guess what
it's corrupt you spend so much time
building something beautiful and keeping
up appearances and lying to the world
lying to the world whether it's you know
about the fact that Kung Fu actually I
don't know works or
that covet came from a bat in nature
Kung Fu works just doesn't help you get
out of a noose right that's true
or it helps you get in the news yes
Google David Carradine yes for people
who don't know and the show kung fu I
also watch Life as a House now let's get
into Russia here because we're talking
about China and this does matter you
know Russia China this is my concern
yeah Russia who cares Russia with China
oh that's worst case scenario that's
world war three type stuff especially if
China starts moving on Taiwan but uh a
lot of groups now have been pushing back
really hard have you seen us with Russia
um bans on things like Russian products
Services uh organizations so there's
been a proactive approach now across the
board from the world's biggest companies
to publicly uh to publicly try and
stifle Russia's ability to
I mean do Commerce right and also
embarrass them on the world we've almost
seen this in the in history before yeah
and it not working out well ever but
this is what they're doing the most
powerful companies and organizations in
the world so here's what apple is doing
specifically in terms of actions and
response pausing all product sales in
Russia also Apple says last week we
stopped all exports into our sales
channel into the country Apple pay and
other services have been limited Russia
Today news and Sputnik news are no
longer available for download on the App
Store outside of Russia Google will sit
on Tuesday that it had blocked mobile
apps connected to Russian news outlets
rtn Sputnik from its Play Store it comes
after the company confirmed that it had
removed Russian state-funded Publishers
including RT from its news related
features including the Google News
Search tool the European Union also
banned our tea and Sputnik with
immediate effect for systematic
disinformation over Russia's invasion of
Ukraine on Wednesday we have just
learned that the U.S Olympic and
paralympic committee is now joining the
ioc and Global Olympic Community angular
in calling for a complete ban on all
Russian athletes competing because
that'll teach them piercing this would
be effective immediately this just
didn't but I've been doping it opening
all Russian teams both National and
clubs shall be suspended from
participation in both FIFA and UEFA
competitions because they were going to
compete anyway so hold on let me just
make sure that understands when you talk
about Apple you're talking about Google
so the Russian government finally became
as offensive as Donald Trump and parlor
were just for existing just to be clear
they were removed from these places a
long time ago it took this long for
Russia to be removed my point is do I
think it's silly yeah I don't think that
any of them should be removed
done but removing Donald yeah I mean do
I need to do a segment
period well especially when you helped I
don't know build them right yeah exactly
it's not like Frankenstein's monster at
this point well let's also talk about
another Point here right Google hey hold
on a second is Tick Tock still available
in the App Store uh by the way the
actual Chinese Communist party has a
stake in Tick Tock it actually has uh
not just to say they can tell you what
to upload and determine what is to be
banned which by the way we still have
not been banned from Tick Tock but we're
gonna do another trash Tick Tock segment
at the end of this I'm going to try my
hardest yeah well I know that the NBA
has probably canceled all their
promotions right kind of broadcasting
deals merchandise deals all of that
right yes because of them killing
uyghurs to use Google as an example
Google YouTube Not only doesn't ban
propaganda from the Communist Chinese
government they will actually adhere to
the rules of the Communist Chinese
government and not allow certain content
to be viewable in those countries this
is a country that commits genocide
I just again the whole idea this is
grandstanding this is virtue signal
signaling on the international stage
look look we're Banning Russia all right
tick tock's gone well
why wouldn't you why would you want to
silence people though and you want to
know what they're doing just on top of
it exactly keep an eye on them on top of
it that's stupid it's that it's that
whole point that you are allowing you
know misinformation and disinformation
and so now you get to just say well this
side doesn't get to get their point out
like and look I am I am pro-ukraine in
all of this we've had these
conversations before but the information
coming out of Ukraine is not necessarily
reliable either we've seen like four or
five stories that have been put out that
have been like well that's not quite
what happened or that didn't actually
happen at all the way that they said it
and so I don't know that Ukraine is
trying to put up misinformation or
disinformation but I guarantee you there
is a war for hearts and minds of people
around the world right now and it would
be stupid of them not to highlight some
of these cases and go see what the
Russians are doing it's bad come to our
Aid yeah and it would be stupid for
Russia not to say see here's what we're
doing if if their goal is to go in and
take over the country just let people
see it people can go back and watch the
state of the union stream that we did
what did former vice president bite what
do you spend a minute and a half on
China well he you know he curated cancer
he's going well he's going again he'll
get around to it but he's doing
Alzheimer's first so you know I got to
knock the big that's like the kid
running for class president and uh free
ice cream sandwiches in the cafeteria
hey oh that starts working on dementia
irritable bowel yes strong strong yes
you know omnicron right
Nancy Pelosi's just ripping her cologne
elderflower because whatever she hears
about bodies burn she turns into the
Gopher from Caddyshack
I'm all right right nobody worry about
me I've got Vodka in my blood I like to
eat ice cream
she is a drunken floozy now she really
is a complete mess of a human being I
know if if my aunt did that at a party
I'd hit her
[Laughter]
what a gross I mean you'd kick her out
yes yes
yeah yeah you would kick it her I'd walk
her to her car and be like oh did you
trip
right in the hood I just saved you bam
oh wait oh this door it seems to be
clicking oh you're such a klutz with
them hey stop hold on can you can you
check the handle is it I'm gonna make
this pencil disappear oh Auntie Pelosi
you fell oh geez looks like he took a
trip looks like your little software
company competing with Microsoft uh
won't be getting off the ground
be ashamed if something was to happen
they're all bullies and thugs when you
think about look at Pelosi's history
look at Kamala Harris what she did when
she jailed people she extended their
sentences for non-violent drug offenses
look at former Vice President Joe Biden
who talked about how he's what he was
going to do with with Ukraine and so
you're not going to get this money it's
just unreal the amount you guys talk
about racketeering
felonies have been committed and my
point here is look don't think it's
always funny to me well like we've
talked about with with Pfizer and we
heard in the Biden speech it was oh
great vaccines and then oh horrible big
Pharma and then you have to go back to
Great vaccines for some reason now
people who talk about campaign Finance
law and Citizens United and people
complain about corporate interests
don't see the card game with Google with
apple with Twitter with Facebook do you
really think that these same people who
let the Ayatollah and and Hamas and the
Communist Chinese Party by the way the
Ambassador from China who said that the
United States military created covid in
case you've forgotten that
these companies who allow that and ban
parlor a conservative app and ban the
sitting president of the United States
they do nothing with communist China
and right now they want you to go oh wow
look well they're really taking it
they're really taking a stand you know
really taking a stand here with Russia
but it's bold and brave it's about as
Brave as Benedict cumber patches chaps
now they're pretty brave and well the
name brand was Brave but yes I thought
they were buffalo turns out they were
Brave The Woolly ones were bold brand
the letter ones were Brave now
what is the net effect of this and we'll
get to how this affects unfortunately
the everyday Russian citizen but of
course one of the effects is people do
stupid things here's a bar owner pouring
out Russian not really vodka so the
naughty parrot Oasis owner says he did
this we pulled any bottle that would
have any tie to Russia so we pulled uh
Smirnoff Stoli a couple Smirnoff flavors
what if someone would say like Smirnoff
is made in USA it is but it's more of a
symbolic gesture you know to get from
his history
that would have any kind of Russian tie
to it I'm surprised he doesn't have
dangly earlobes after uh the spacers the
Muk dangly ones but David just followed
a trend in his life it's the naughty
Parrot Bar yeah it's so original how's
that Vampire Weekend tattoo aging you
prick getting it covered what we're of
Montreal but hey what'd you do I'm
sensitive about it three years from now
in the butt bar with his buddies what's
that uh what's that Imagine Dragons neck
tattoo I can't get a job
it's purple and yellow now it's for
Ukraine yeah I love Ukraine I'd have an
international studies now do me a favor
point it out on a map yeah if someone
told you to be on you are you uh
Russia's side you would have been yes
exactly did it get rid also he got rid
of all Rocky 4 DVDs yes oh that was made
in America yeah but it had features of
there's a Russian guy in it so uh
do you know you're you know your beard
bomb uh comes from Russia well yeah but
I'm not I can't be without look I'm
making sacrifices but I'm a human yeah
yeah what about the uh six or seven
hundred thousand barrels of oil we buy a
day well I thought that we were getting
green energy I drive a you don't I don't
need to worry about uh uh energy I drive
a Tesla ah oh how do you charge it son
of a [ __ ] yeah I'll plug my car and
tell everyone how great I am yes and
wait for four hours so I can go tell
other people yeah I tell everyone to do
it and if everyone actually followed my
advice we would have no electrical bed
left I say glitter grid I don't know I
don't know what I said yeah your air
conditioning and heat would go out every
five minutes right it'd be like Texas in
an ice storm only always yes
clip Steve this is great though the
planet's not dying Ted Cruz just has a
one way to Cancun that time well joking
smart man that kind of so sorta the
world and here are some other
consequences the world athletic Council
uh they didn't just ban Russian athletes
you could understand that I think we
should have ban Russian athletes you
know for steroids
but by sorry I mean government assisted
rampant steroid programs systematic
doping yes exactly okay all right it's
almost like The Jetsons you know where
like the little duster comes out only
it's a syringe into a Russian athlete
now they've also banned Belarusian
athletes well did you just and here's
the thing the Ukrainian Parliament they
tried to report that Belarusian troops
invaded the Ukraine that's what they
said and just like you've been talking
about there's misinformation on all
sides doesn't mean that our hearts are
not with the people of the Ukraine any
innocent life lost is awful but it
doesn't mean that the Ukrainian that
the Ukrainian government yeah because
it's Ukraine not the Ukraine but but the
Ukrainian government okay don't get old
hold your comments you don't know the
rules I mean comment because you know I
always want you guys to comment but I
know people have said that I've said the
Ukraine in the past I don't know why
I've said that but the Ukrainian
government so the Ukrainian government
yeah
yes they reported that Russia Belarusian
troops uh invaded right
um the U.S intelligence said no hmm no
no evidence of that well the Belarusian
president said no yeah so we don't
necessarily know but I'm going with
probably no I mean it's likely that that
could happen and will happen so that's
the thing I don't know who to trust here
right I have no idea my own government
right now I'm like I don't know you guys
said Russia collusion doc was A-Okay and
here's the real real problem with this
too is is well there's there are quite a
few problems but there's misinformation
yes and then Google Facebook Twitter
Apple they're going to determine what is
misinformation hey that's worked like a
charm with
I mean ever point to any example
elections
covid the Russia story with Donald Trump
the the the the the uh the hunter Biden
story right they've never they've it's
always been fantastic when you put the
Power of what information is allowed in
the hands of I don't know four companies
and jensaki threatens them on the stage
like I'm not trying to affect private
companies but if you want to come to our
wine mixer looking at you looking at you
whatever the guy's name is at Apple
who's not Steve Jobs what's his name I
always forget his name
it's just Tim Cook and Brian still
throwing a water bread Pete butt cake is
ready to sign on that's a Secretary of
Transportation that's the kind of
secretary you don't want bringing your
coffee in the morning very loud on the
western back no creamer very sticky now
they've also had bands uh on
on Russian businesses and let me get to
kind of the danger that here so uh Nike
online sales Disney film releases UPS
and FedEx shipments Visa Mastercard
network access that's kind of a big one
Apple and Google pay it may not seem
like a big deal but a lot of services in
Russia uh for example the Moscow Metro
runs on these Services now
wait a minute but how will Nike make a
profit from slaves well they'll do it
everywhere else they still have their
stuff made in China they're all good no
exactly as long as children are still
making my shoes I'm gonna sleep well and
your phones so that people can be banned
from the app store on it yes I just want
to make sure that child yeah I got an
idea U.S company if you're making stuff
in Russia right now you really want to
show us that you care if you're making
stuff in Russia I don't think you should
do this but don't don't go halfway we'll
talk about it a second close your plant
in Russia yeah you're not gonna do that
you're just gonna keep doing stuff in
China be like well we're not going to
sell that plant would be converted into
making AK so fast yes it's like oh I see
this used to make this used to make
bouncy up for children parties now it is
ammo yes we have guns with 23 on them
they're through yes we should our guns
are not made to tight tolerances but
they are good for killing children fire
still three times piano wire hurts hands
yes these laces are kind of nice
so there's like some sanctions make
sense okay right it makes it hard to
finance War I understand that but why
here's these kinds of sanctions go after
the everyday they go after the average
Russian citizen so who's affected by
well we know here in the United States
who's affected by these energy just
absolute quagmires when we're talking
about Nordstrom too we're talking about
shutting down uh our own pipelines here
right fracking when we're talking about
the I keep forgetting the name of that
pipeline Keystone Keystone Keystone just
think of terrible beer think of Keith
Stone excuse me
who's affected American you're right Joe
former Vice President Joe Biden he even
said that he even said that in his
speech it affects you the Americans when
you look at a lot of these sanctions
when you look a lot of these policies
well who does this affect it this
doesn't Joe Biden said he was going
after oligarchs
by shutting out Apple and Google pay and
visa and MasterCard access do any of you
actually believe that that only affects
the multi-billionaire oligarchs no it
affects the average day Russian Citizen
and here's my work you either need to
this is basically an act of War without
declaring war this is an act of War
without declaring war and I think you
either go into war or you have nothing
to do with it I do think it's pretty
black this is where a gray area is
counterproductive
creating sanctions okay I understand
creating sanctions so maybe it makes it
tougher to fight but creating crippling
economic sanctions for the government
and for its people wow by the way doing
nothing
nothing to curtail the relationship
that's growing with Russia and China
so you don't you're not going after the
head of the Beast you're not even going
after the Beast you're going after the
flower you're going after the citizens
who have nothing to do with it so I
don't know what the play is here maybe
someone can maybe you can fill me in you
can comment below I don't see the I I
it's very hard for me to see the point
of view I guess maybe they're hoping
that the Russian citizens or that there
will be dissent that they'll rise up
against their government which obviously
very unlikely because they could be
killed but there's also another
possibility they just hate the American
West we've seen this happen before this
is the problem sometimes with wanting to
spread democracy to places that don't
really want it
that power vacuum by Saddam is that was
filled like a charm oh yeah worked out
well let's look sanctions can sometimes
work if they're done thoughtfully and
not when you're dealing with a Madman
like Putin and I say madman because he's
a madman and everybody's thinking like
oh he's just he's just acting reasonably
based on what he's trying to do and I
get that he's angry what he's trying to
do is mad that's my point pranking more
right so if you sanction somebody like
that you have to understand one they've
probably thought okay when I do this
they're going to do that they play chess
in Russia have you ever heard of it then
he's going to prepare for that and like
we've said China all too willing to try
and pick up the slack all too willing
and so all you're going to do is push
him to a point where he has to make a
decision citizens are going to come to
him at some point and be upset and try
to topple him he knows that what do they
typically do
send more police forces into the streets
to make sure you quell any dissenters I
don't know if that's the case though
the Americans I might become upset with
the American West because
American West won't let uh because of
the former Vice President Biden your
Diners Club no longer work yeah but
he'll make that argument and it'll work
for a minute but then people will just
get pissed off that life sucks now and
that the government isn't making the
payments that they're supposed to make
and take care of you with those bread
lines that we know are so fair that's a
good thing right they're not going to be
able to do it and then eventually
they're going to come for his head
that's what happens not always it's
sometimes they don't sometimes they
don't sometimes before they come for his
head they see it as a benevolent
authoritarian government and they think
that he'll protect them and right now
especially when he's uh he's sort of
presenting that he's looking out for
Russia's national interests which by the
way to a degree he is I understand his
perspective they might say okay this is
this is our champion this is the problem
when you have the United States meddling
when the United States is going in and
these sanctions do not affect Putin
these sanctions do not affect his Rich
buddies these sanctions affect the
average day Russians who are trying to
get on the subway they're trying to get
in their Metro
that's that's a problem that's a problem
because not only does it drive the
Russian government into the arms of
China which is a problem internationally
just to keep again keep your eye on
China and Taiwan just so you know if I
seem like I'm a non-interventionist I
believe if a single missile is fired to
Taiwan from China it needs to be the
most Swift and violent military action
for the United States that well it's not
been seen since World War II and our
Navy needs to be right on their Shores
completely I need it needs to be 100 all
in with Taiwan and China and I think
that we're going that way My worry is
not Russia My worry is China but we've
done nothing
we've done nothing to to make them uh
less powerful on the world stage if
anything we've made them more powerful
by allowing them to be on all of this
these social media apps they're so
emboldened right now that they're doing
the the heavy lifting for the Russian
government right they're the ones going
out condemning Americans for sanctions
so Russia oh our Russia Today can't uh
can't have a YouTube channel meanwhile
the Chinese Ambassador ambassadors
whatever the role is Xi Xing ping they
can go out and say whatever they want
condemning the United States supporting
Russia and the Russian citizens that's
what they have access to is that
information this is not a good situation
you either need to go in war is go in
break [ __ ] take the [ __ ] that you didn't
break that's the only reason to go into
war and usually that person should be an
undesirable person but that's not how
always how it's been sometimes it's just
because you want to take their stuff
just to be clear we're the first world
superpower do you know that
do you think the English Empire do you
think the Ottomans would have stood for
Canada's [ __ ] they were the Ottomans
they didn't stand the English only
became an Empire because they did take
all of the other stuff right come on and
if the French had won a war in the last
uh 9 000 years come on they do the same
thing look at look at this is one thing
that's look at the English Empire right
look at the church look at the look any
Empire look at look at uh Genghis Khan
any of them the show Empire look well
they were growing until Jesse smallett
and that's what I mean but if you look
at any Empire you can look at a map and
it grows very quickly and I mean monthly
certainly yearly how long has the United
States pretty much been the same border
and I know you guys can talk about but
it's continental United States Canada's
a bigger landmass than the United States
it is unlike any other Empire that's
ever existed by the way we also have the
ability to go take over stuff over do
you know that
you think Russia would actually stand a
chance
think about this for a second you think
Italy Ireland
no we don't do that because we're not
the kind of Empire that by the way
established these other countries this
is something people don't understand and
this is a for me not only War but I
don't I would like to hear you because
the stream was really long uh on the
night of the State of the Union but this
is something I feel very strongly about
and I know people will say it's harsh
some of you might disagree with me I'd
like to hear your comments below uh NATO
I think the NATO spending increased 50
billion under Trump For the First Time
The reason why is uh NATO write the
promise if you join NATO is uh you spend
two percent of your GDP on effectively
you know military that's uh available to
Nato that's a simplified version all
references of available at lotto.com the
United States I believe I'm going by
wrote put in 3.4 percent and there were
only two other countries I believe it
was Greece and one other country that
put in more than two percent a lot of
people were under one percent now the
whole idea of NATO
is everybody saying okay we all agree
right we want to we want to make sure
that we stop this threat so we're in
this collectively we all agree that this
is the amount that we will pay in okay
that's fair they didn't pay in
as far as I'm concerned because you
talked about when they attack another
NATO country that's my line with Russia
yeah that's that's your life or that's
that's uh that's a lot of people's lines
yeah that was uh Lanes line with Russia
you know what my line is
if they attack another country whose tab
is 100 paid in full in NATO
don't get to say that you're a part of
NATO which is really just by proxy going
to the United States saying please
please please help us if you didn't pay
for your [ __ ] how about that you talk
about how internet is a human right in
Germany and all these European countries
socialize Healthcare well I'm really
glad that you're able to pay for your
frivolities because the United States
pays more than all of you combined we
should not be protecting any NATO
country
that hasn't and I don't mean starts
paying two percent from here on out no
pay your tab from all of history or
you're out are you starting to get the
picture
you mean you're okay if they take over
Latvia yep
I assume they're I'm okay if they take
over any country that has not paid their
share no I think that's a fact that
basically means that we'll only go in to
protect Greece yeah I mean when the
other country in the world that's the
superpower is picking up the heavy tabs
and you're just like ah we're just going
to take care of our citizens and make
sure that they get all the free stuff
they want listen we're not the people
with the problem with Russia we weren't
the people with the problem with Germany
there's a reason that we came to your
Aid yes we don't want these things to
happen well eventually we did well
eventually I mean we let we let it
happen for a minute Germany by way of
Japan well that's true we were going
that way anyway we were just super
isolationist at the time does it feel
familiar right now we're getting very
very very isolationist and what we
should get involved and what we
shouldn't and I get it I understand why
but that's not the world that we live in
the world that we can just sit on the
sidelines and let stuff happen anywhere
you're right though if we do form these
agreements you got to live up to them or
we're not coming sorry yeah if you're
not doing your job I'm not doing mine
how
how beneficial is NATO to the United
States
honestly
generally what what does the United
States get out of NATO you say we need
you
think about this for a second no they
entirely benefit from the United States
really there doesn't need to be a NATO
affordable if we're going to go into
every country every time there's a war
that you guys don't like
just just have the United States
military you know what just pay us
directly then how about that pay us like
we're like we're a sole proprietorship
we're an independent contractor we're
the Suge Knight of the world and we'll
dangle Putin over a balcony like vanilla
ice just pay us don't act don't create
this this house of cards this shell game
like oh NATO International defense it's
[ __ ] the only reason that these
other countries in the modern anytime
you point to an example of a successful
socialist model which by the way isn't
actually socialist like Denmark or the
Nordic model it only exists because of
the veil of protection provided by the
United States and I know that you I
think that veil of protection needs to
be removed because guess what we'll be
fine we will be fine some of these other
countries won't be and it's time for you
guys to start picking up the tab it's
time for you guys to start paying for
your own defense it's time for you guys
to stop mocking the United States and
looking down your nose when you provide
a bunch of free [ __ ] to your citizens
because your military's just a bunch of
guys in tug boats with shotguns how
about that now
speaking of this I don't even know
speaking of this here's a clip from Sean
Hannity who just said something that I
think is very silly about the Russian
Convoy that's approaching this is the
kind of and I don't think Sean Hannity
is a bad guy don't get me wrong no
but it's the kind of mindset that gets
us into Iraq's
you know if we can see on satellite
imagery where the Convoy is I don't know
maybe some smart country maybe NATO
might take some of their fighter jets uh
or maybe they can use some drone strikes
and take out the whole damn Convoy and
then nobody takes credit for it so then
Putin won't know who to hit yeah I'm
sure I'm sure Putin will leave it at
that it'll be a mystery
idea in this day and age who did it yeah
yeah I don't know they just blew up like
Jackson Pollock not putting his
signature on I guess we'll never know
yeah no clue no idea you full boots in
the game oh well I'll go back to my very
long table and salt but crying out loud
you have any idea how do you have any
idea how misguided that is yeah
just uh commit an act of War commit an
act of war and don't take credit for it
and uh I'm pretty sure that uh tomorrow
will be a better day no no no no no no
that just pisses people off more don't
go into war unless you plan to win has
anyone asked what does a win look like
and I know we're here I know where
you're but even you you Jill because
you're not as non-interventionist as I
am what does a wind look like if we get
involved in this conflict because to me
the only win is we have Russia's oil
and they start speaking English and we
convert them to Christianity and I know
they're technically a lot of Christian
Nation but not really a win uh you know
the hard part is that you don't know
what long term this country would look
like Russia right so when for me is that
they know that if they get aggressive
with any of those countries and just try
to take over another country that NATO
will stand up and keep them back that's
a win for me not America getting
involved but right NATO if look Sean
Hannity's point is not without Merit
that if there is a convoy coming
somebody needs to take them out that
needs to be Ukraine in this situation
right or if NATO is prepared and ready
to go and I know we're a part of it then
yes NATO go take it out but don't stop
there get all of their forces out of
Ukraine and show Putin this is not going
to happen otherwise you're just going to
piss him off more and Ukrainian citizens
are going to die right which is
happening right there to just starve out
Ukraine citizens and then see if we can
wait for as long as possible for them to
build a super duper power ah yep yes see
how long it takes for them to make a cup
Foods well you never know if this is the
first step towards like something bigger
or if this is just the extent of the
action I think that's the hard part here
so I think it's bigger it usually is but
they've gone into it but here's the
thing if it is bigger the people in
power right now don't give a [ __ ]
because what it's not acting correct
what does bigger mean means China and
Taiwan yeah they can't address that
Biden can't address that or Russia
Facebook YouTube Apple cannot address
that they can address it so if this is
bigger fine but then tell us what bigger
is and tell us what a win is this is
where I think Americans have a problem
with you know this sort of foreign
policy people say policing the world and
I know we're not really doing any we're
not we haven't taken military action
against Russia yet
but it's basically a declaration of war
without declaring war when you're you're
you're you're starving out citizens
you're squeezing them from daily life
and then if we're a part of NATO that
basically only benefits from our
membership and you attack a convoy and
not take credit for it as Sean Hannity
says
what did you think happened to my top
oligarch advisors we don't know good
enough for me okay they didn't call and
say they were coming yeah you normally
do well that's rude was that about
anybody I don't know it could have been
you I've heard it fashionably late but
lots of people are dying ah they knocked
and ran this is not how International
diplomacy should be handled the kill
that person Mighty was called
foreign
to me is Russia no longer exists as
Russia they are no longer powerful
period okay and uh China stepped down
and we basically eliminate any kind of a
threat with Taiwan that's a win break
their [ __ ] take what we want the oil is
ours
why are we doing why are we shutting
down our own oil Reserves
well and I know now Nordstrom 2 was shut
down after Europe decided to do it and
was like yeah put my name on there
there's no reason for war unless it
benefits this country and by the way
there's no reason for us to be in NATO
unless it benefits this country NATO is
great in practice I certainly don't
think we should be in the U.N but I
think we put a pause on all our NATO
spending until everybody else catches up
certainly if they want to do stupid
things like fire a missile at a convoy
and not take credit for it and act like
their patent
I think there's no perfect solution
that's the hard part here no there was
actually what it was going over and
talking to the guy letting him know
where you stood and letting him know
there were eyes on him no no I mean yeah
but it's true though I mean there was a
solution in the sense of at least you
were able to keep business as usual yes
instead this guy comes out completely
ignores him which is going to piss off
any megalomaniac yeah yeah and then
everything that every way that he
handled this is wrong he turned his back
to a guy who was completely insane and
this is the result yeah you don't back
someone into a corner unless you're
going to eliminate them exactly if you
back him into a corner and then he's
like huh eventually I like that corner
event yeah exactly yeah I don't I don't
yeah why do you keep saying this I don't
like corner I can't sit at Logan I told
you corner is unpleasant do you like it
no stop saying that I already said I
don't like it you're saying the opposite
of what I say hey why you do why are you
hitting yourself Putin I'm not I am not
you're using my hands this is you you
stop doing it stop it
that's not me everyone for record he is
hitting me with my own hand
got your nose you give that back my nose
yeah he at least felt some level of
dignity and power and I'm not saying
that he deserves that but you kind of
want that in another League exactly so
they don't go crazy and start murdering
people why why back him into a corner in
the international theater think about
that for a second I mean I hate to use
this because all everyone acts as though
there's somehow This brilliant military
strategist when they quote Sun Tzu but
this is one this is he's not wrong it
says build your opponent a golden bridge
to retreat across right that's one of
the tenets of Wars you you need to give
them an out and I think if our goal here
is ending the conflict while minimizing
the the
minimizing the amount of Life lost to as
little as possible
and sometimes that's unpleasant for
example do you know what minimized lost
life in World War II
dropping the a bomb
a lot of people don't like that it was
going to go to a land War so if
minimizing the loss of life here means
wiping out someone who you think is a
genuine International threat then wipe
them out
but if it's not
I get it our heart all breaks for people
of the Ukraine however
you have to decide you really do have to
decide if you are all in or all out
because life will be lost no matter what
you have to look at how can we minimize
the amounts of Life loss and by the way
going forward we absolutely need to tear
a page from that's one thing I noticed
from the State of the Union Address he
did not want to do the Trump's fault
Trump's fault Trump's fault you know why
because no one would buy it would anyone
actually buy for a second
that former Vice President Joe Biden is
tougher on China would anyone actually
buy for a second that Russia was acting
up more under Trump than they are right
now would anybody actually believe for a
second that Trump weakened NATO
of course not
and that's what we need to go going
forward we need to be firm going forward
we need to make sure that people in NATO
pay their fair share oh but that's mean
you're paying 0.6 of your GDP well we
pay 3.4 now you start getting your ass
kicked and we're supposed to come in and
save you
you're lucky we don't break your thumbs
that's just me
right but the point though if any would
the point would be made all right you
know what we have a lot to uh we have a
lot to get to here on chat Thursday go
to a lot of clutter.com tour Dave and I
are on tour and he's going to be uh
Hartford Funny Bone YouTube I don't
really just piss off
foreign